Quand j'y repense,
à ce premier été à Rome,
et que je vois les changements des six dernières années,
c'est une transformation totale.
C'est le début des données dans le monde humanitaire.
C'est excitant, c'est motivant,
mais on n'y est pas encore.
Tenez-vous prêts, dirigeants,
parce que je vais mettre des sociétés
sur la sellette pour qu'elles fassent ce que je sais qu'elles peuvent faire.
Mes expériences à Rome prouvent qu'en utilisant des données,
on peut sauver des vies.
D'accord, peut-être pas à ce premier essai
mais on y est arrivé.
Laissez-moi vous brosser le tableau.
Imaginez que vous devez prévoir petit-déjeuner, déjeuner, dîner
pour 500 000 personnes
et vous avez un budget limité,
disons 6,5 millions de dollars par mois.
Que faites-vous ? Quel est le meilleur moyen de procéder ?
Achetez-vous du riz, du blé, des pois chiches, de l'huile ?
Quelle quantité ?
Ça a l'air simple, ça ne l'est pas.
Vous avez 30 aliments possibles et vous devez en choisir 5.
C'est déjà plus de 140 000 combinaisons différentes.
Puis, pour chaque aliment choisi,
vous devez choisir la quantité à acheter,
où vous allez l'acheter,
où vous allez le stocker,
combien de temps ça prendra à arriver.
Vous devez aussi étudier toutes les différentes voies de transport.
C'est déjà plus de 900 millions d'options.
Si vous examinez chaque option pendant une seconde,
ça vous prendra plus de 28 ans à parcourir.
900 millions d'options.
Nous avons crée un outil qui a permis aux décideurs
de trier ces 900 millions d'options
en seulement quelques jours.
Ça s'est avéré très efficace.
Lors d'une action en Irak,
nous avons économisé 17% des coûts,
ça voulait dire qu'on était capables de nourrir 80 000 personnes en plus.
C'était grâce à l'usage de données et la modélisation des systèmes complexes.
Mais on n'était pas seuls.
L'unité avec laquelle j'ai travaillé à Rome était unique.
Ils croyaient en la collaboration.
Ils font appel aux universitaires
et aux sociétés.
Si nous voulons changer les choses
pour les problèmes comme la faim dans le monde,
nous avons besoin de tout le monde.
Nous avons besoin des gérants de données des ONG
pour nous montrer la voie
et pour orchestrer les bons types d'engagements
avec universitaires et gouvernements.
Et il y a un groupe qui n'est pas mobilisé autant qu'il le devrait.
Vous avez deviné ? Les sociétés.
Elles ont un rôle à jouer dans la résolution des problèmes du monde.
Je travaille dans le privé depuis deux ans.
J'ai vu ce que les sociétés peuvent faire et ce qu'elles ne font pas,
je pense il y a trois façons dont on peut combler cette lacune :
en donnant des données, des scientifiques décisionnels
et de la technologie afin d'acquérir de nouvelles sources de données.
C'est la philanthropie des données,
c'est le futur de la responsabilité sociale des entreprises.
En plus, c'est du bon sens commercial.
Les sociétés aujourd'hui, elles amassent des montagnes de données,
donc la première choses à faire, c'est donner ces données.
Certaines sociétés le font déjà.
Prenez par exemple, une entreprise de télécom.
Ils ont partagé leurs données au Sénégal et en Côte d'Ivoire
et les chercheurs ont découvert
qu'en étudiant les pings envoyés vers les antennes relais,
on peut voir les déplacements des gens.
Et ça peut nous informer sur des choses comme
la diffusion du paludisme, grâce à ça on peut faire des prévisions.
Ou prenez, par exemple, une société satellite innovante.
Elle a partagé et donné ses données.
Avec ces données, on peut voir
comment la sécheresse influe sur la production alimentaire.
Avec ceci, on peut déclencher des financements d'aide avant une crise.
C'est un bon début.
D'importants enseignements sont enfermés dans les données des sociétés.
Et oui, il faut faire attention.
Il faut respecter la confidentialité, par exemple en anonymisant les données.
Mais même si les barrières s'ouvrent,
même si toutes les sociétés donnaient leurs données
aux universitaires, aux ONG, aux organisations humanitaires,
ça ne suffira pas à maîtriser toute l'influence des données
pour des fins humanitaires.
Pourquoi ?
Pour libérer des idées des données, il faut des scientifiques décisionnels.
Les scientifiques décisionnels sont des gens comme moi.
Ils prennent des données, les nettoient,
les transforment et les mettent dans un algorithme utile
qui est le meilleur choix pour répondre au besoin commercial.
Dans le monde de l'aide humanitaire, il y a peu de scientifiques décisionnels.
La plupart travaillent pour des sociétés.
Donc c'est la 2ème chose qu'une société a à faire.
En plus de donner leurs données,
ils doivent donner leurs scientifiques décisionnels.
Ils diront : « Ah ! Ne nous prenez pas nos scientifiques décisionnels.
Nous avons besoin de tout leur temps. »
Mais il y a un moyen.
Si une société donnait un bloc du temps d'un scientifique décisionnel,
ça serait plus intéressant, d'étaler ce bloc de temps
sur une période longue, cinq ans par exemple.
Ça représenterait seulement quelques heures par mois,
ça manquerait à peine à la société,
mais ce que ça permet est très important : des collaborations durables.
Des collaborations durables construisent des relations,
permettent de connaître les données, de les comprendre
et de commencer à comprendre les besoins et défis
que l'organisation humanitaire doit surmonter.
A Rome, au Programme Alimentaire Mondial, cela nous a pris cinq ans,
cinq ans.
Les 3 premières années concernaient ce qu'on ne pouvait pas résoudre.
Les deux années suivantes, nous avons affiné et mis en œuvre l'outil,
comme pour les actions en Irak et dans d'autres pays.
Ça ne me semble pas un délai irréaliste
quand il s'agit d'utiliser des données pour faire des changements opérationnels.
C'est un investissement. Ça exige de la patience.
Mais les types de résultats qui peuvent être produits sont indéniables.
Dans notre cas, c'était la capacité de nourrir des milliers de gens en plus.
Donc on donne des données, des scientifiques décisionnels
et les entreprises peuvent aider d'une 3ème façon :
donner de la technologie pour capter de nouvelles sources de données.
Il y a beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles on n'a pas de données.
En ce moment, des réfugiés syriens inondent la Grèce,
l'agence de l'ONU pour les réfugiés a du pain sur la planche.
Le système actuel pour suivre les gens est un papier et crayon,
cela veut dire
que quand une mère et ses cinq enfants entrent dans un camp,
le siège est essentiellement aveugle à ce moment.
Tout ceci va changer dans les semaines à venir,
grâce à la collaboration du secteur privé.
Il va y avoir un nouveau système basé sur des dispositifs de suivi
par la société logistique pour laquelle je travaille.
Avec ce nouveau système, les données sont tracées,
donc on connaît le moment exact
où cette mère et ses enfants entrent dans le camp.
On peut aussi savoir si elle va avoir des provisions
ce mois et le suivant.
La visibilité de l'information entraîne l'efficacité.
Pour les sociétés, utiliser la technologie pour recueillir des données,
c'est la routine.
Elles font ceci depuis des années
et ça a entraîné des améliorations de l'efficacité opérationnelle.
Imaginez votre entreprise de boissons préférée
essayant de planifier leur inventaire
et ne sachant pas combien de bouteilles sont sur les étagères.
C'est absurde.
Des données entraînent de meilleures décisions.
Si vous représentez une société,
si vous êtes pragmatique et pas seulement idéaliste,
vous vous dites peut-être : « Tout ça est très bien, Mallory,
mais pourquoi devrais-je m'engager ? »
En plus d'être bon pour l'image,
l'aide humanitaire est un secteur de 24 millions de dollars,
et plus de 5 millions de gens, des clients potentiels,
qui habitent dans les pays en développement.
De plus, les entreprises s'engageant dans la philanthropie des données,
trouvent de nouvelles idées enfermées dans leurs données.
Prenez une société de cartes de crédit
qui ouvre un centre
qui sert de hub pour les universitaires, les ONG et les gouvernements
qui travaillent tous ensemble.
Ils étudient des informations lors de chaque usage de carte
et utilisent ceci pour trouver des données sur comment les familles en Inde
vivent, travaillent, gagnent et dépensent.
Pour le monde humanitaire, cela fournit des informations
sur comment on peut sortir les gens de la pauvreté.
Mais pour les sociétés, cela fournit des informations sur vos clients
et clients potentiels en Inde.
Tout le monde y gagne.
Ce que je trouve excitant concernant la philanthropie des données,
-- le don de données, de scientifiques décisionnels et de technologie --
c'est ce que ça signifie pour des jeunes professionnels
qui veulent de travailler dans des sociétés.
Des études montrent que les nouveaux travailleurs
veulent que leur travail ait un plus grand effet.
Nous voulons changer les choses,
et grâce à la philanthropie des données,
les sociétés peuvent aider à engager, retenir leurs scientifiques décisionnels.
Et c'est un facteur important pour une profession très sollicitée.
La philanthropie des données fait sens commercialement
et ça peut aussi aider à révolutionner le monde humanitaire.
Si on coordonnait l'organisation et la logistique
à travers tout les facettes majeures d'une opération humanitaire,
on pourrait nourrir, habiller, héberger des centaines de milliers de personnes.
Les sociétés doivent se bouger et jouer le rôle dont elles sont capables
dans cette révolution.
Vous avez sans doute entendu l'expression « nourriture pour la pensée ».
Ici c'est vraiment une pensée pour la nourriture.
C'est enfin la bonne idée au bon moment.
(Rires)
Très magnifique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)